you keep watching because although the
baby has some incredible power without
having to wield the dark saber
I think the baby is so curious about
what this is so when you will be
enthused and inspired when you see the
scene of referring to in the season two
which is to comment October to March it
feels powerful it feels wonderful with
someone else and which I'm hoping you
will enjoy when you see major major epic
epic lightsaber action happening on this
show and I should mention that I'm the
only character in this first season who
was able to be honored with having that
lightsaber so it feels wonderful I feel
like we need to be able to physically I
love to be able to touch the baby oh my
goodness that baby's ears or you just
touch it's just so cool it really feels
real as well welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is gonna be my new
Mandalorian season 2 video Giancarlo
Esposito the person who plays Moff
Gideon was talking all about what's
going on with baby Yoda and all the dark
saber lightsaber fight scenes that he
has during season two so we'll break it
all down if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I'll be doing mandala rain season 2
videos during the off season also talked
about when they're gonna release the
Mandalorian season 2 trailer we'll just
do this top 5 WTF style starting with
number 5 Giancarlo Esposito was at a
comic-book convention recently talking
about the Mandalorian season 2 what's
gonna happen with his character moth
Gideon now that we know he has the dark
saber and he's already had his first
encounter with the Mandalorian baby Yoda
and his team he spent a lot of time
talking about what he had to change when
he was filming with the dark saber
versus using a normal type of sword in
scenes implying that there will be a lot
of him using the dark saber which i
think was just a big tease at the end
the season why would you whip something
out and then not use it a bunch during
season two but the way that Star Wars
films lightsaber fight scenes in general
is a little bit different when he says
he's wielding the dark saber because
physically like the hilt in the actual
blade itself the dummy blade that they
use when they're filming behind the
scenes is a little bit different from
traditional lightsabers he says that his
version of the dark saber that he's
using in scenes has a shorter hilt in
the blade is shorter than most
lightsabers so the way he strikes people
with it is a little bit different than
you would strike someone with a
traditional sword most lightsabers are
all individual and unique to each Jedi
that creates them or each Sith and if
you're like Anakin Skywalker and you
have a lot of technical prowess you can
actually make a much more advanced
version of a lightsaber so for instance
on Anakin's lightsaber you look there's
a lot of extra buttons and dials those
are for adjusting the blades length its
width there are a lot of other Jedi's
that make lightsabers like that but some
can be made to be a little bit more
simple like Luke Skywalker's green
lightsaber that he bills before Return
of the Jedi that doesn't have any
special adjustments to it so it's one
single length the entire time there was
a bunch of Giancarlo Esposito talking
about the physicality of using the dark
saber that I cut out of that clip but he
does go on for awhile just talking about
pure fighting technique as an actor
during another part of that clip he also
talks about accidentally destroying
three dark sabers onset during a
particular season two lightsaber fight
scenes it's supposed to be crazy so
number four WTF what is that dark saber
or light saber fight scene that he's
referring to
well they tease the dark saber at the
end of the Mandalorian episode aid so of
course the next step in season 2 is
watching him used the dark saber on
someone else either killing a random
henchman or a New Republic soldier like
his own version of the rogue one Darth
Vader ending scene where he just tears
through all those rebels in the hallway
also consider this at the end of the
Mandalorian Episode eight the armor gave
the Mandalorian his mission to find any
Jedi capable of taking baby Yoda to care
for him and train him as a Jedi so
presumably will see more former Jedi who
survived order 66 just hiding out in the
Outer Rim since Moff Gideon has the dark
saber it's also implied he may have
stolen or collected a bunch of Jedi
lightsabers and keeping them as trophies
maybe at some point he fights someone
who just gets their hands on one of
those if he's saying that he's gonna
have a badass lightsaber fight with the
dark say
it implies that he's fighting someone
who also has a lightsaber and so far we
haven't seen any other lightsabers on
the Mandalorian yet and there's only a
couple ways to get one I think based on
what the actor is saying Giancarlo
Esposito his character is just a very
learned in Jedi history in Jedi lore he
wasn't a Sith Inquisitor or anything
like that he sounds like he was someone
who was in the Imperial Security Bureau
who just uncovered a lot of Jedi
artifacts after the fall the Jedi Order
at order 66 in the Great Purge of
Mandalore like it's implied that he
stole the dark saber at some point after
the Great Purge so if he's stealing the
dark saber in Mandalorian artifacts it
wouldn't be too much of a jump to see
him stealing a bunch of Jedi artifacts -
so early prediction I'm hoping that once
we get the chance to see where his
personal quarters are wherever his
flagship is he has a lot of other Jedi
artifacts decorating his office and
personal spaces we saw him used the
special Thai Outlander so I'm hoping
that there's at least a Star Destroyer
as his flagship since there aren't very
many of those left in the galaxy after
the fall of the empire in the remnants
of the Imperial fleets were either
destroyed at the battle of jakku or fled
into the Unknown Regions to become the
first order even though the bulk of the
Imperial fleet that was left over fled
into the Unknown Regions there are still
lots of Imperial assets and ships just
all over the galaxy being taken over by
warlords number three WTF he says during
that clip that Moff Gideon does get his
hands on baby Yoda sometime during
season two he didn't say which episode
he just says he gets his hands on him
and he has a bunch of scenes with baby
Yoda and as an actor he just loves
working with the puppet version of the
child and scenes but his character Mothe
Gideon thinks more of baby Yoda is a
tool to wield in his attempt to bring
quote-unquote order to his territory and
based on the implied cloning plot that
they teased through dr. purging his
character eventually used baby Yoda's
power to take over the entire galaxy but
if you watched all the Star Wars movies
you think about that for a minute I'm
really curious to see how this plays out
because as badass as he seems the
Mandalorian series isn't gonna break the
pre existing Star Wars Canon set up by
the movies and that also includes the
new movies and if those are happening
about 25 years after the events of the
Mandalorian series 25 to 30 years
depending on how much time passes
between force awakens and rise of
Skywalker
during that
period in the future there's no sign or
mention of a moth Gideon no clone army
of force-sensitive troopers that he
grafted off of baby Yoda's DNA not
counting all the Rebs it's troopers from
brides of Skywalker those were all
different they don't have anything to do
with Moff Gideon plan but it all just
implies that Mothe Gideon is not
successful or he doesn't survive into
the events of the new movies or he's
redeemed himself turned good one of the
other interesting things that Giancarlo
Esposito said attracted him to the role
of Mothe Gideon in the first place as a
villain was the idea that there could
possibly be some redemption for him so
it's possible he winds up trying to help
baby yoda by the end of the series
instead of just using him like a tool
number two this is also really cool he
said that baby yoda also filmed scenes
with the dark saber and within the
series baby yoda is completely
fascinated by it probably because it's
so shiny and babies like shiny things
that make noises he kind of addresses it
during his talk there but we all know
that baby Yoda is more intelligent than
he looks and during the panel Giancarlo
Esposito talked about how he's very
intuitive and understanding for a baby I
mean he is 50 years old so even if Yoda
species matures very slowly compared to
humans he's still waste smarter than a
human baby at a comparable age and
clearly he's demonstrated his
understanding of the force enough to
know how to force heal people which is a
very complex ability no matter how
simple rise of skywalker made it seem
but he does make it pretty clear that
there's no way baby yoda
is taking the dark saber from him during
season 2 or the Mandalorian for that
matter at least they won't take it from
him permanently
I like his rebuttal to those kinds of
questions like no no way definitely not
gonna be taking that from me anytime
soon
but anything is possible in the future
so it just means that in a future season
the Mandalorian mic is hands on the dark
saber the whole reason that George Lucas
created the dark saber for Clone Wars
was because of Jon Favreau's Pre Vizsla
character in the Death Watch
Mandalorians which we're also gonna see
during the Clone Wars season 7 episodes
when they created that character Jon
Favreau and Dave Filoni felt like there
were so many Jedi that Pre Vizsla would
be going up against during the Clone
Wars that he needed some special weapon
to make him a physical threat to them
they went to George Lucas and together
they came up with the concept of the
dark saber then Dave Filoni came up with
its backstory within the Star Wars
universe
so same logic Moff gideon himself isn't
a big physical threat to the mandalorian
without some special weapons so that's
where the dark saber comes in it just
gives him a big edge in combat in number
one WTF does Moff Gideon himself saying
that he gets his hands on baby Yoda
during season two implied that they're
gonna do an empire strikes back style
sequel season downer ending like a
cliffhanger where he still has baby Yoda
at the end and they hit into season
three Return of the Jedi style opening
with the big Mandalorian led rescue
mission to save him I mean if most of
the Mandalorian series takes its
inspiration from the original trilogy
they're gonna hit some of those same
beats it's totally possible they do
something similar and if you think about
it Moff Gideon would be a real
character if he wasn't able to make good
on any of his threats which he's made
very clearly at the end of season 1
assuming the series runs for four or
five seasons is just easy WTF slam dunk
to do at least one Empire Strikes Back
style ending cliffhanger to a season but
post all your theories in the comments
below what kind of lightsaber battles do
you want to see with the dark saber and
what kind of scenes with baby Yoda in
Moff Gideon do you want to see I think
we all just want to find out what's
going on with his crazy implied cloning
plot that dr. Pershing was talking about
the Mandalorian season - release date is
in October we're getting episodes even
earlier than we did last year so really
nice surprise
but I'll keep doing bonus videos while
we wait for the trailer to get here the
Mandalorian season 2 trailer will
probably drop sometime in the next
couple of months
everyone click here for all my
Mandalorian episodes and click here for
my new Star Wars the Clone Wars season 7
episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome this is
the way
[Music]